in 2007 NASA sent the Dawn probe to go
explore Ceres and Vesta the biggest
rocks in the asteroid belt right now the
spacecraft is focusing in on Ceres which
is about forty percent the size of Pluto
dawn is getting a great look at the
asteroids topology those are dust
covered craters in blue and towering
mountain peaks in a red and those
features are getting some new names to
one of series most mysterious craters is
now named I adore it shows off two
bright spots that could be anything from
a salt deposit to ice to a volcano
there's another bright spot which used
to just be called spot one now it goes
by how lelani for the Hawaiian plant
goddess a number of event bigger craters
are being named for other harvest
deities humans may never get the farm on
series but the astronomical name are
sure want to after all series was named
for the Roman goddess of agriculture